well yeah i think the global economy can
still be made to work for america we are
still one of the top recipients of
foreign direct investment in the world
this whole discussion of sovereign
wealth funds that money doesn't need to
go only into Wall Street to bail out
private banks and their and their
misdeeds and wrong decisions and poor
judgments it can also be channeled into
broader infrastructural investments in
America that build up our capacity to
create jobs to boost our high-tech
productivity and so forth in ways that
make America's long-term global economic
presence sort of renewed for the 21st
century which happens again only in
certain pockets we brag about Silicon
Valley we have very low broadband
internet penetration rate around the
country far lower than in Europe for
example so we do need a serious
infrastructural overhaul and with our
deficit right now obviously we need
foreign capital to do that for us so if
we were able to redirect some of that
creatively it's a failure of imagination
really on our part we still stand the
chance of making America competitive
well it's interesting leave the perfect
example of how to reconcile it is Latin
America we face competition from Asian
producers that are far cheaper and more
efficient than than we are but we have
Latin America which is very inefficient
but yet very close to us if we were to
invest in Latin America for productivity
and joint exports with Latin firms or
American owned firms in Latin America we
could potentially be or become as a
region or a hemispheric kind of area
more competitive with Asia and profit
more from it but we don't do that but we
did do it in the 1960s it was called the
Alliance for Progress and it worked and
it built the infrastructure abase in
brazil argentina and elsewhere so to do
things like that again would really
serve american interests but we haven't
been as as broad in our investments as
we need to be in those countries in
order to keep them afloat and find ways
to partner and leverage what they can
export to the world in order to profit
ourselves